you see how long this video is yes you
get to enjoy this long-ass video for
free and that's thanks to our sponsors
like war thunder check out this game
through the link in the description
below go through that link and not only
do you support this show you get a free
premium tank or aircrafts in three days
of premium time as a bonus and let's get
into it so imagine for a moment that you
can travel backwards through time and
give your 16 year old self the powers of
a god imagine placing the lives and
fates of millions into your trembling
teenage hands with the result be a
happier world a utopia or would it be a
catastrophe for everyone involved
including your younger self in October
54 ad the Roman Empire made this little
thought experiment a terrifying reality
they elevated an emotionally unstable
16-year old boy to the position of
Emperor that boy's name but it was Nero
the last of the Giulio Claudian
Emperor's niro transforms the greatest
empire the world has ever seen into a
playgrounds for his darkest desires yet
his own mother murdered ordered
Christians burned alive for
entertainment and indulged in
perversions so shocking that make the
Marquis de Sade yet he died beloved by
Rome's commoners and convinced that he
was the greatest artist who had ever
lived join us today as we investigate
the life of the most infamous Roman of
all
if you were to take a quick glance at
the backgrounds of Nero you might assume
the Emperor had a childhood of
unparalleled luxury born Lucius Domitius
enobarbus on December the 15th 37 ad
Nero was a member of the Giulio Claudian
dynasty aka the dudes who had been
ruling Rome for decades his mother
Giulia Agrippina commonly known as
Agrippina the younger was a direct
descendant of the first emperor Augustus
and his great uncle was Claudius but
while my son like a tickets you life on
remand Easy Street Nero's mother Agra
Pina could have told him differently the
Giulio claudia n--'s enjoyed nothing
more than fratricide the Roset started
way way back when Agri Pina herself was
just a girl growing up with her brother
Caligula as you'll know if you've
already watched our Caligula video Agra
poenas dad was a popular general who was
in line for the imperial throne so
naturally Agra poenas adopted
grandfather the emperor Tiberius had him
poisoned in 1980 it was just the first
in a long line of Giulio Gordian family
murders so let's jump ahead to 37 ad
Tiberius is dead and Agra poenas brother
Caligula inherits the throne at first
things were fine it was during this
period of calm that Agra Pina gave birth
to Nero but then Caligula had one of his
trademark Kaku moments and decided Agra
Pina was plotting to kill him so he took
all of her property and banished her to
a tiny islands where she could have no
contact with her son dumps with a random
aren't young Nero was forced to make do
with a dancer as a tutor if that sounds
that early kind alright well just know
that dancers actors and poets were
considered the lowest of the low in
Roman society basically no better than
prostitutes it seems likely Nero's arms
felt there was no point wasting good
money on a boy who might not live long
anyway knowing Caligula's paranoia it
would be a miracle if nero reached his
fifth birthday but thank Jupiter that
miracle happens on the 24th of January
41 AD the elite praetorian guard
assassinated Caligula stabbing him to
death outside the Palantine Games they
then marched straight to Claudius and
declared him the new emperor so there
was this blink and you'll miss it moment
at the start of this video where we
mentioned that Claudius was Nero's
great-uncle well that meant
Rapinoe was Claudius's nice and unlike
Tiberius or Caligula Emperor Claudius
was all about not killing his relatives
no sooner had Porteous taken the throne
than he recalled Agra pinna from her
exile at last reunited with her son Nero
a Gravina swore she would never again be
left sits the mercy of her cruel and
capricious relatives bat meant getting
her wealth back that meant building her
own power base but how was a penniless
Widow meant to do that in a patriarchal
society like Rome well you just leave
that Agri Pina first Agri Pina pressured
her uncle to find her a husband so
Claudius forced a consul to marry her
next Agra Pina poisons that console and
inherited his wealth then came 48 ad in
Claudius's execution of his wife barely
it was her body cold than Agri Pina was
seducing the Emperor's advisor and
giving him an excellent plan why didn't
Porteous just marry a crappy no the
proposer was dressed up as a way of
uniting the two Giulio Claudian branches
and ending France resides once and for
all but really it was just an excuse for
a drippy nose to get closer to power
while Claudia's got to live out his
creepy incest fantasies On January the
1st 49 ad Agra Pina became Empress one
year later Claudius adopted her son Nero
in 10 short years Agra Pina had taken
herself an arrow from pariahs to the
heart of Imperial Rome they had money
and they had power but never forget that
Agra Pina was from a family that prided
itself on killing it's useless members
and well what use did Empress Agra Pina
have now for her uncle Claudius
[Music]
come 51 ad all was not well in Rome's
Imperial Palace
that same year Agra Pina had pressured
Claudius into naming Nero his co-heir
alongside the Emperor's natural son
Britannicus with Nero suddenly in line
for half the throne Claudius his
advisors were taking a bit of a closer
look at him and when they took that
closer look they did not like what they
saw by now a teenager Nero was a sulky
spoiled brat he would rather spend his
time learning to play the lyre than
learning how to rule we're still the boy
was developing a bit of a cruel streak
one by one people started to wonder if
they might just have another Caligula on
their hands yes they were really
powerless to stop Agrippa from building
her son's power base in 53 AD Agra pinna
force Nero into a marriage with Claudia
Octavia the daughter of Claudius when we
say force dear we really do mean it
Claudia Octavia was being pursued by
another suitor at the time Agra Pina
erect that portrait and drove the suitor
to suicide yet even this marriage of
convenience and wasn't enough to
convince Agra Pina that she was safe and
that another Caligula wouldn't just come
along and Driver and poverty again the
only way to do that was to make herself
answerable to no one on the 13th of
October 54 ad Emperor Claudius he
suddenly died ancient sources speculate
that Agra pinna bribes the Emperor's
taster and septum poisoned mushrooms
whether that's true or not the results
were absolutely the same control of the
empire went to Claudius's as Nero and
Britannicus or rather that's what should
have happened at the moment Claudius
died only Nero was old enough to be
considered an adult Britannicus was
still a child and legally incapable of
ruling
so when Agri Pina presented Nero alone
to the praetorian guard and asked them
to salute their new emperor
there was nothing Britannicus could do
aged only 16 Nero was elevated to be the
sole ruler of the world's most powerful
empire and let's just pause here for a
second to imagine just how Agri Pina
must have felt that day against all the
odds should overcome a childhood of
tragedy and an adulthood of XR to
install herself at the very heart of
Roman should murdered her second husband
[ __ ] manipulated and killed an emperor
and now
her son was on the throne we hope Agri
Pina savored that moment we really do
because it just wasn't destined to last
very long just as his mother had started
to wonder if she really needed tortillas
the new emperor nero started to wonder
if he really needed Agri Pina
before long Agra Pina found herself
being slowly pushed out of the corridors
of power determined to find the wily
murderess trying to allow herself with
Britannica's only the nero to have a
stepbrother poisoned not long after iraq
Rapinoe was moved out of the palace to a
little villa on the outskirts of Rome
even the previous marriage had secured
for nero with claudia Octavia it was
destroyed as nero took up instead with
papaya sabina as a last-ditch effort
Agra Pina made overtures to Nero's
cousin suggesting that they could depose
the teenage Emperor together but Agra
poenas luck
well it had run out in 59 AD Nero had
Agri Pina bought a boat that was
designed to sink and drown her when she
managed to survive the grueling swim to
the shore her son simply ordered her
stabbed to death it is said that as she
realized what was about to happen Agra
Pina pointed at her womb and screamed
stab me there where the monster had been
nurtured Junior Agri Pina died on March
23rd 59 AD after the news leaks out Nero
in a bit of a half-assed effort trying
to tell everyone that it had been a
suicide but no one in Rome was under any
illusions they knew what had got down
the young Emperor he had broken the
greatest abbu killing his own mother
Claudius as advisors have been wrong
Nero wasn't the next Caligula he was
something much much worse
now you probably have a bit of a mental
checklist prepared for the rest of this
video fiddling as Rome burns check
persecuting the Christians also check
well don't worry we're going to get to
those dubious highlights but before we
tell you about Nero the crazy Emperor
we've got to tell you about Nero the
insanely popular Emperor that's right he
was really really popular for all his
name may now be synonymous with
decadence niro started his reign
actually being quite a cool dude prior
to Agra poenas death Nero had banned
secret trials cracked down on corruption
and handed powers back to the Senate he
also slashed taxes banned capital
punishment granted more rights to slaves
banned animal blood sports and tried to
phase out planet Oriole combat and
replace it with Greek wrestling it's so
popular were these measures that the
great Emperor Trajan would later declare
Nero's first five years as the greatest
reign in Roman history and it's here
that we finally reached one other
contradictions surrounding Nero despite
all the mad stuff he did he was beloved
by his subjects Nero had a common touch
that other Roman elites lacked after his
death a whole generation of ambitious
provincials which claimed to be Nero's
heirs as shortcuts popularity so why
then do we only hear about the bad stuff
maybe it's because the common folk
didn't ride The Histories neither did
the ambitious provincials but rather the
money to Roman elite it and those guys
they couldn't stand the way that Nero
debased his office the issue was this
unlike August's Tiberius or Caligula
Nero had never wanted to be Emperor
it was Agri Pina who had schemed him
into the palace and into power the other
reluctant Emperor Claudius had at least
been old enough to understand the
responsibilities of office
Nero though he was young enough to
understand that the responsibilities of
office could kiss his Roman ass no long
after Agra Peter's death Nero talks
openly about giving up the throne to
become a full-time poet but the power
that came with being a living God was
simply too much fun so instead Nero
began to live an artist's life parallel
to his Imperial one the young emperor
spent his spare time partying in
brothels grousing with actors hanging
out with lowlifes people like to get
drunk and appear onstage in theatres
sometimes in female roles
remember the Romans thought that artists
were lower than sex workers seeing Nero
indulge his artistic side for them was
sort of like seeing the Queen of England
naked for cash in the namste dam brothel
and you're welcome for the Hat mental
image although what happens next a
better monocular comparison might be
Henry the eighth in 6280 Nero's mistress
papaya Sabina became pregnant since Nero
was still married to the popular Claudia
Octavia this caused a bit of a scandal
so Nero divorced Claudia and banished
her into exile and underhands move that
was about to get even more underhanded
when the people of Rome protested her
banishment Nero had his ex-wife murdered
it was the second time it killed a close
relative and just as with a gravina Nero
vaguely made out that had been a suicide
in reality it was yet another blood
stain on the artist Emperor's hands and
it would certainly not be the last but
before we get into all of those
bloodstains you should absolutely check
out war thunder as a smooth transition
war Thunder is a realistic free-to-play
military vehicle combat game war thunder
is available on PC ps4 and Xbox one but
you only need one of those consoles in
order to play no need to purchase either
just download and get going in this game
there are over 1200 historically
accurate vehicles from the 1920s all the
way to the 1990s they're all carefully
built and incredibly detailed and
physics has really been worked on to
make it all rather rather good and the
sounds also pretty amazing
and look you can just jump in for a
quick arcade game useful if you don't
have much time that's what I tend to do
or you can play realistic and go for the
more challenging tactical stuff or if
you're hardcore you can play simulator
but you know that's just really like
getting their arse whipped over and over
again so join us on the batter with free
using the link below doing that support
to the show it's a free way to support
the show by the way and you also get a
free premium tank or aircraft and three
days of premium time as a bonus just for
registering and let's get back to Nero
by July the 1864 ad Emperor Nero's
initial popularity it was in terminal
nosedive the same year Nero had Claudia
murdered at the Praetorian Guard prefect
Boris had died a natural moderate had
kept the emperor's darkest desires in
check so why did near 80 he replaced him
with a guy called Tiger Lin us who
thought the best thing the emperor could
do with his dark desires was absolutely
let them loose that meant orgies bloody
purges of the elite and even fewer hacks
given about representing the office of
Emperor come that hot July of 64 AD the
people of Rome were fed up with the
Emperor Aaron's ready to believe just
about anything about him and into this
tinderbox of resentments came a very
real spark the causes of the Great Fire
of Rome are lost history
all we know is that on July the 18th the
conflagration swept through the Eternal
City at the time Rome was a collection
of wooden shacks that had been thrown up
without any central plan so when the
inferno gone going it really got going
the fire burns for a week by the time it
fizzles three of the city's districts
had been destroyed in the Imperial
Palace itself had been damaged and what
was Emperor Nero doing while all of this
destruction took place well know what
you're thinking is absolutely wrong I
mean the one thing that everyone knows
about Nero is that he fiddled as Rome
burns but it turns out that that is
actually total bunk Nero wasn't even in
the city at this time far from regarding
the fire as a source of amusement
Tacitus tells us that Nero raced back to
Rome and spearheaded the relief efforts
he even lets hundreds of those left
homeless by the disaster stay in his
imperial palace this kind of raises the
question well why do we think that Niro
fiddled while Rome burns well there's
two reasons one involves a building and
the other involves a Jewish cults so
let's tackle the building one first once
the fire was over Nero pledged to
rebuild Rome grander than before in most
respects he succeeded constructing a new
city with streets wide enough to hinder
future fires however he also decided to
build a massive palace atop the rubble a
palace that included a 120 foot tall
statue of himself for all Roman public
there's already leaning
an tiny road this was just too much
rumors started to swell that Nero had
set the fire himself specifically so
that he could build this stupid palace
panicked
Nero decided that he needed to find
someone to blame rather fast his chosen
scapegoats were surprised surprise a
Jewish sect known as the Christians in
64 AD Rome's Christians were a small
cult comprising of non-citizens refugees
and Greek speaking Outsiders like
foreigners refugees and immigrants sadly
discover all too frequently that made
them perfect targets on Nero's orders
prominent Christians were tortured until
they confessed to starting the fire Nero
then said about having them all rounded
up and gruesomely executed unlike the
tale of Nero fiddling all the stories
you've heard about his torture of the
Christians are absolutely true
Christians really were torn apart by
wild animals
Nero really did have them burned alive
to illuminate his garden parties perhaps
as no wonder early Christians came to
seriously hate Nero there's a theory
that the Antichrist in the book of
Revelation was meant to symbolize this
Emperor but it wasn't just the
Christians who disliked Nero's
persecution the extreme torture
inflicted were disturbing by even Roman
standards in the Senate in the
Praetorian Guard people began to whisper
to one another that things were getting
out of hand they were beginning to
whisper that it was time to get rid of
their arsonist Emperor but they hadn't
counted on just how hard to kill Nero
would turn out to be
[Music]
when people want to prove just what a
monster Nero was they usually point to
his actions in 64 AD allegedly letting
Rome burn and actually slaughtering the
Christians really though they should
point to the Emperor's antics the
following year
if 64 AD was Nero at his most
misunderstood 65 ad was Nero at his
psychotic peak it started out when a
Senate plot against Nero was discovered
what followed was a purge that saw 23
conspirators forced her to commit
suicide along with the philosopher
Seneca
but if 23 dead doesn't sound so bad know
that this was just the warm-up act in
the wake of the conspiracy niro brought
back the treason trials that had been a
feature of Tiberias and colliculus rules
kangaroo courts that convicted and
executed people on a whim the treason
trials were infamous for being an
underhanded way for the emperor to get
rid of anyone that he didn't like an
arrow in 65 ad he had an enemies list
longer than war and peace yet even this
bloodshed doesn't compare to Nero's
cruelest act that year at some point
that summer
Nero got into a blazing rail with his
wife you might remember her that's
prepare Sabina the mistress who got
pregnant causing Nero do murder his
previous wife well if a payor probably
should have realized that ordering your
wife's assassination isn't a great sign
for marital stability
according to Tacitus Nero mad with rage
kick prepare to death the poor girl was
pregnant at this time and Nero made sure
to aim his vicious kicks at her swollen
stomach in the aftermath of this brutal
double murder
Nero went insane he had papayas stuffed
and embalm dinner cops deposited in a
mausoleum so that he could visit it
whenever he wanted free here still Nero
caught sight of a 13 year old boy a few
weeks later who was the spitting image
of his murdered wife known as porous
this unlucky boy was kidnapped by Nero's
men and castrated Nero then forst's
poorest to dressing clothes belonging to
the dead preparer and married him in a
bizarre service after that spores could
be seen dressed and acting like the dead
Empress sat at Nero's side as the
deranged Emperor kissed and fondled him
if this wasn't already creepy enough
Nero himself took to wearing a papaya
mask when he performed on stage
embodying the girl whose life it so
viciously snatched away
yes even as he drifted into Norman Bates
territory Nero did not lose his common
touch the next year 66 AD he left on a
tour of Rome's eastern provinces
effectively giving himself a year's
break from running the Empire but rather
than react to this creepy murderer the
way the elites in Rome and those in the
East acted like Nero was an ancient rock
star the thing was narrow he knew how to
play a crowd in Greece he dressed like
an ascetic with bare feet and flowing
hair and took an active interest in the
country's new religions wherever he went
he granted towns free city status
ensuring the inhabitants celebrated him
he was so popular that he even took part
in the Olympic Games unsurprisingly won
every event that he ends it it seems
Nero himself felt being in the East was
a form of freedom it again appearing on
stage more and more often playing the
roles of pregnant women when he go back
to Rome up a society it was more
scandalized than ever the Nero was wrong
if he thought that he could just keep
violating norms and doing whatever the
hell he felt like the Emperor he didn't
know it yet but his days on this earth
while they were already numbered in
early 68 AD Nero sends an order to the
governor of Gaul a guy called VIN Dex
telling him to raise local taxes it was
just one of many such orders that Nero
is in the habit of sending out to fund
his lavish lifestyle but this time
something was different Nero didn't know
it but VIN Dex was at breaking point fed
up with endlessly having to raise taxes
on golf index snapped when he saw Nero's
latest demand
he took up arms and declared himself in
rebellion against the Emperor but then
he did a funny thing he declared
allegiance to the popular governor of
Spain a guy named Galba this was funny
because galva was very much not in
rebellion when he heard of index's
declaration he freaked out and declared
himself for Nero but just hearing VIN
Dex mentioned Garber was enough to send
Nero's paranoia into overdrive and he
had both men declared enemies of Rome
realizing he was doomed either way Galba
wins well screw it and declared himself
in rebellion after all unfortunately for
Nero a popular governor leading a
rebellion was exactly the news that Rome
had been waiting for as news of Galvez
revolts hits the Praetorian Guard came
out in support of him as did the Senate
as did a huge
of the army as did well everybody on the
night of June the 9th 68 ad Nero woke up
to find his palace empty he sensed the
end was near everyone had deserted the
Emperor as Nero ran through the empty
cavernous rooms he screamed first for
help and then for someone to kill him
when no voices came in reply Nero is
said to have whales have I neither a
friend nor foe but the Emperor he was
wrong he had plenty of foes across the
city the Senate had calls an emergency
meeting seeing which way the wind was
blowing they declared Nero an enemy of
Rome and dispatched soldiers to finish
him off but Nero was no longer in his
palace accompanies by a handful of
slaves and one Freedman Nero had fled to
a darkened villa four miles outside of
the Eternal City he had been able to
make it to the east of the empire where
it was still popular where he might have
stood a chance but that chance it
slipped through his fingers and now
there was only one way that this could
end as the soldiers closed in on his
hiding place Nero is said to have
started muttering to himself what an
artist dies in me he demanded his slaves
kill him
but to no avail finally with the
soldiers right outside and Dawn finally
breaking Nero snatched a dagger from
someone and plunged it deep into his own
throat the soldiers stormed in divine
the emperor knelt on the floor his tunic
soaked with blood with what we imagined
must have been an unhinged grin on his
face
Nero supposedly delivered one last
immortal line to the men sent to kill
him too late Emperor Nero died that
morning unloved and alone a pariah to
his people with his death Juliet
Claudian line that had ruled Rome since
it became an empire was snuffed out the
fratricidal family that had given the
world's the highs of Augustus and the
lows of Caligula would produce no more
Emperor's but if anyone was expecting
Nero's death to herald an era of
stability well they were in for a rather
rude awakening in the wake of Nero's
suicide Gabbar was made Emperor but he
ruled a mere six months before he was
assassinated
galvez death which plunged the empire
into chaos 69 ad would see four
Emperor's come and go before the dust
settled and for space Ian claims the
throne but all of that that's for
another video
what of Nero what of the man we came
here to discuss although he's infamous
today
as the most decadent Emperor you could
argue that Nero wasn't the worst sure he
did some terrible and inhuman things but
even his cruelest acts weren't the
outright sadism of Caligula as much as
they were the lashings out of an angry
teenage boy who never mentally grew up
it's true that Nero was a nasty man and
an unhinged pervert but it's also true
that his badness is sometimes
exaggerated
he never fiddled while Rome burns the
first 10 years of his rule they were
even something of a golden age while
it's fitting that we remember the awful
vicious side of Nero it's also worth
remembering that history is more nuanced
than it often appears Nero was deranged
but hopefully in our video today we've
shown there was more to him than simply
being Rome's crazy Emperor so I really
hope you found that video interesting if
you did why not give us a thumbs up
below it really does help also subscribe
and hit that Bell button so you find out
when we put out new videos also and
linked in to some other videos from the
archives on the screen now please do
check those out if you are so inclined
and as always thank you for watching
you